hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 2 video
big Captain America reveal from the
comics a lot of Doctor Strange crossover
and like a big reveal for a ghost
writers character so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet because there's so much stuff
happening today this is gonna be a
little bit different but there's just
like a couple really big things in this
episode so they revealed who the
director of shield is it's Jeffrey as in
Jeffrey mace but they've done a bit of a
twist with his character from the comics
so Jeffrey Mays was the patriot in the
classic Captain America comics he
eventually went on to wear the mantle of
Captain America so Captain America
effectively is the new director of
shield they named drop cap in the
episode like he said the reason they
chose me is because we needed a powered
person who the public could trust in
Captain America is on the outs he's
still a fugitive as of the end of civil
war but the twist is is that you know
like Captain America Super Soldier Serum
super-strong powered person so Jeffrey
mace on the TV show says I prefer the
term inhuman and then just totally soaks
all of Mays damage or just just like
tries to bash him and it doesn't even
faze him so the idea is is that he kind
of has a version of the Super Soldier
Serum in him he's super strong he kind
of has a Luke Cage thing going on
only the explanation is is that he's an
inhuman which is not the case in the
comics so it's a bit of a twist so in
modern continuity Steve Rogers is the
only person who's ever worn the mantle
of Captain America you know maybe
somebody else in the future of the
Marvel movies will pick up the mantle
but if that does happen it will only
happen in the movies they probably won't
address that on the TV show other than
like I feel like them teasing Geoffrey
Mays you know potential Captain America
from the comics they'll let him wield
Captain America's shield on the TV show
like they don't give you a tease like
that the fact that he is a super soldier
and a good person without letting him
throw down sometime during the season
so I mean you guys can let me know in
the comments but don't you feel like
after that reveal they're gonna give him
some moment in a future episode or maybe
the second half of the season where he
just beats the
out of some criminals they mention
agent Carter when Coulson was taking the
government people on the tour so I feel
like that's just more i winking at
patriot the Geoffrey Mays character from
the comics because that's kind of the
era that he came from but really hoping
that they let him wield Captain
America's shield even though you know
he's probably not gonna wear a special
costume he'll probably just dress like
the other shield agents but the Ghost
Rider stuff so we learn more about the
actual spirits on the TV show The Ghost
Rider he sent one back to hell so you
actually see that ability for the first
time he's able to neutralize the spirits
in a way that the other people are and
they examine the containment device it
looks a little bit like it's mystical
tech but the explanation so far has been
scientific and it looks like they were
trying to harness energy from another
dimension Allah
agent Carter season 2 if you didn't see
agent Carter season 2 which you probably
didn't because the show got cancelled
because nobody was watching it they
dealt with the idea of the Dark
Dimension dark matter which is Doctor
Strange Dormammu so in the Doctor
Strange trailer that I just posted they
talked about harnessing energy like
there's literally energy from other
dimensions that they use to weave their
magic so it sounds like scientists on
agent Carter and now on Ghost Rider
agents of shield have been trying to use
that to gain power like personal power
they even mentioned a book so there's
probably a book of magic that will be
revealed on the TV show and it went
wrong causing them to be out of phase
with this dimension but they sound
pretty evil and as ghostwriter sends one
back to hell he only protects the
innocent these people are not innocent
but when he tells Daisy that he's the
thing that connects them all what I
think is they're gonna reveal and this
will be a little bit of a twist from
Robby Rhea's in the comics is that the
spirit of vengeance that he is bound to
is his uncle and his uncle is the one
that's responsible for what happened to
these people so his uncle will be tied
to this facility because he seemed
really like extra interested in what was
going on beyond the idea that they're
just terrible people like when Daisy
mentioned the name of the facility his
ears perked up big time
so I'm guessing what
sold his soul the person that he sold it
to was his uncle and he was responsible
for all this so it's a bit of a change
from the comic book origin story like
it's not involved with any of this stuff
but really the big reveal here is is
that the ghosts have a plant like the
spirits have a plan there's a book of
magic involved and this version of ghost
riders origin story is tied to that so
there are a lot of great moments I like
the direction that it's going I mean
there were a couple moments where it's
slowed down during the episode but you
have to remember this is like a 22
episode season so I'll be interested to
see if they resolve this spirit plot the
first half of the season and then move
on to something even bigger than the
second half usually that's what happens
like the first part of the season they
have a really big arc to get you pumped
up they resolve it relatively quickly
like the mid-season finale but in doing
so that kicks off something even bigger
like there's some big twists and another
spirit of vengeance rises up and it
becomes more about that like we've only
just started learning about this version
of Ghost Rider so I feel like as we
learn more about the spirits they're
planned this mysterious book of magic
that they're trying to use we'll learn
more about ghost riders character so let
me know what was your favorite moment
from the episode was it like the Ghost
Rider using his powers seeing him burn a
soul send it to hell or learning about
the Captain America director of shield
the other really cool thing and I'm
really happy they're doing this is that
they made may go crazy I feel like she's
gonna have so much more fun now because
her big thing up to this point is in not
showing emotion and now she's like off
the deep end she's just flying a part of
the seams so I feel like you know one
it's gonna be fun for us to see her go
crazy on everyone
- it's probably even more fun for
ming-na the actress to play this they
kind of do that every year with some of
the flash characters like Tom Cavanagh
comes back every year on the flash as a
different version of his character so he
has a different personality gets to play
him in a different way it's just way
more fun for the actors and it's kind of
fun for the audience too so the next
episode is called uprising as in inhuman
uprising there are people that are
trying to stop inhuman registration so
we're still feeling the blowback from
the sokovia accords they've mentioned
those at
four or five times in the last two
episodes and then they also follow up
with what's going on with meso like at
the end of the episode we see May going
crazy in the Quinn jet as it's flying
away Fitz in Radcliff are gonna try and
help her I'll be interested to see how
they weave that into the life model
decoy because any time Fitz in Radcliff
are together I feel like they're gonna
follow up on the life model decoy
storyline but maybe they'll have made
just like completely go apeshit on ADA
the one great crime of the may character
is that they didn't make her the
Jennifer Walters she-hulk but what's
gonna happen next is they just dropped a
giant arrow trailer with a whole bunch
of season five footage they also teased
Supergirl arrow crossover for like the
big four night crossover and there's a
whole bunch of flash season 3 stuff so
those videos will post next so I'll try
to get that out as fast as possible most
of it will post Thursday there's also
some cool Game of Thrones stuff that I'm
working on but I can't really talk about
that till it post what you guys wait for
that stuff to post you can click here
for that Doctor Strange trailer and you
can click here for all my other Ghost
Rider videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight